MOVE A
LEAD PASS.
CRAIG SMITH THERE
AS MURRAY DIVES ACROSS AND THEYT
AFTER THAT THE GOAL IS POKED IN
BY
FIRST MINUTE TRENT FREDERICDNICA
THERE. THEIR
IDENTITY AND PLAY THAT WAY EVERY
>> OTTAWA LIKES TO USE THAT UP
HIGH INTO THEOINT AND JOSH
THEIR ZONE AND OTTAWA CATCHES ON
TO IT.
THE REBOUND IS OFF MURRAY OUT.
THE SPAS PICKED OFF.
AND A TO D TO BROWN.
HALL.
THEY LIKE TO THROW THE PUCK
ALONG AND BUNT IT BACK INTO A -D
RECOVERING FROM A B B PUCK.
TO FIND
AND HE'S DOWN AND THEY POKE HIM.
HALL BACK THE OTHER WAY.
LONG S S
OTHER WAY.
ANTON BLIDH WITH THE SHOT AND
REBOUNDD ON NET.
HE DOES AND DRIVING TO THE NET
>> 22nd RANKED POWERPLAY IN
THE LEAGUE FOR OTTAWA.
POWERPLAY.
WE STALKED ABOUT BADGER RON AND.
TO PASTRNAK AND DOWN LOW FOREHAN
TRAFFIC.
SHOT 22-8 YOU'RE A
SHOT GET
THE PUCK BUT NOT OROM THEM AND S
GLOVED DOWN.
HE HANGS ON.
>> Mike: OTTAWA CONTROLS THE
AND IT'S
OVER TOFRONT.
ALL ALONE.
WHAT A SAVE BY MATT OPEN FOR
MCAVOY.
THEY SCORE. IT'S BLIDH
COMING AROUND THE BACK OF
TO RUN INTO GOALTENDERS BUT
THERE A SUCCESSFUL
COACH'S CHALLENGE FOR SMITH AND
OTTAWA SENATORS. BLUELINE.
KEEPS IT ALIVE.
CHABOT IN FRONT. ALIVE AGAIN
AND A COUPLE OF REALLY GOOD
IT'S WIDE OF THE GOAL AND OVER
AND TO OF THE NET.
CONNOR SWAYMAN.
HOW ABOUT THIS ONE?
TKACHUK FROM BEHIND THE GOAL.
BANGING AWAY.
SWAYMAN'S GOT IT AND HE HANGS AN
SOLID THIRD PERIOD.
HE MADE REALLY NICE SAVES AND HE